je reçois maintenant robert lamoureux
pour la parution chez plon de par trente
six chemins
un récit autobiographique dans lequel
lamoureux et graines à travers papa
maman la bonne et lui le chapelet de ses
souvenirs souvent ému parfois amer d'un
demi-siècle de seine et comme on le
disait tout à l'heure et comme on le dit
depuis 50 ans rassurez-vous le canard
est toujours vivant salut robert alors
bon par trente six chemins c'est donc
votre autobiographie qu'on voit à
l'image pendant qu'on pendant qu'on
discute tous les deux on va en parler
bien sûr avant j'aurais dire un mot de
la pièce donc ça s'appelle si je peux me
permettre cette au théâtre des
nouveautés troisième faire georges
pendant le troisième année troisième
manuel 600 représentations 824 non oui
en plus fort que ce que je croyais 824
je crois même que c'est 834 et c'est
rare à notre époque parce qu'avant
c'était assez courant ça finalement
oui c'est à dire que par exemple jean
piat bon compte il avait fait le
tournant il avait fait 900 fois il y a
la pièce de ionesco qui est joué depuis
1950 à la huchette boing boing pendant
vingt ans le record je crois que ces
patates c'est plus de 1000 en tout cas
2255 j'aurais pu
et vous vous êtes monté à les
statistiques incroyables est monté seize
mille fois sur scène avant plus que ça
parce que j'ai jamais fait que du
théâtre
après alger à l'esr du cabaret oui ah
oui c'est vrai que ces générations
wallon sortant du théâtre aller vite à
l'amiral l époque de jean marc thibault
les années 50 et roger d'aller ailleurs
enfin je remontais régulièrement de dwi
deux fois sur scène par jour ouais alors
ça fait peut-être même plus que 16 mai
déjà fait prendre demi alors la pièce
bon on en dit un mot c'est un c'est plus
un spectacle de chansonniers qu'une
pièce de théâtre non si je peux me
permettre au oui oui on peut on peut on
peut dire ça mais en fait il ya quand
même une pièce construite bien entendu
et à partir de ces de cette solidité la
cette structure il arrive que les
événements extérieurs joue un peu le
reflet des vous en rajoutez un peu quoi
j'arrive nouri al horria balutin le
fameux jacques balutin qui lui fait un
personnage un peu à la bernard tapie et
puis à vous qui rêviez de jouer un
personnage de larbin est là pour le coup
vous le jure et entraygues
on se régale alors on va passer à votre
bouquin parce qu'en fait c'est bon c'est
votre si votre autobiographie vous êtes
né en 1920 ce qui fait que vous allez
bientôt avoir 80 ans comment j'ai tout à
l'heure
de père en fête de pères inconnus pas
vraiment c'est ce que vous dites au
début de votre livre parce qu'en fait
votre père votre mère l'avait connu dans
wii dans une opinion n'a pas lâché d'une
formule admirative c'est ça et de père
inconnu ma mère le connaissais très bien
d'ailleurs en 1932 vous raconter ça dans
votre boucal vous emmène un jour du côté
d'angoulême pour rencontrer pour
rencontrer votre père que vous
connaissez à l'âge de 12 ans quoi ouais
c'est trop tard ouais mais pour moi ça a
été le pire c'est qu'il est mort en 1932
donc
finalement trop tard dans tous les sens
parce que je voulais dire et vous alors
un jour vous retrouvez un fils caché à
vous aussi c'était vraiment avait un sas
et les énoncer des suites de guerre
c'est celui de gharbi souci c'est avant
la pilule quoi dire que maintenant les
robes homme attend que ça se produirait
plus bas ouais c'est les romanciers vont
et plus et enfin elle serait prise en
charge l horaire ils vont être embêtés
les romanciers maintenant parce que aura
plus d'enfants ketch écrire ça c'est
fini
alors dites moi vous avez vous avez dans
le livre vous dites que vous avez le
certificat d'études
ah oui oui j'affirme oui mais dans le
moose vous vous dites que vous avez le
brevet vous avez un peu exagéré sont
trompés mais je n'ai jamais osé dire que
non alors vous raconter alors bon on va
pas tout raconter mais c'est vrai que
c'est assez marrant parce que donc venir
donc en 40 fait la drôle de guerre
vous vous retrouvez dans les chantiers
de jeunesse ensuite dans les cévennes et
vous dit contrairement à beaucoup de
français qui sont vantés de d'avoir été
des grands résistants
vous vous dites finalement la résistance
je suis venu tardivement et sans grand
risque c'est vrai ouais c'est vrai j'ai
navigué de façon afin de faire prendre
par les allemands ouais je me suis pas
beaucoup soucier d'autre chose pour
vérité alors un jour bon vous constatez
vous dites mon mariage est un échec et
vous partez en algérie alors c'est
marrant et un truc je comprends pas avec
vous puisque l'om ben on vous dit avoir
du succès dans toutes ces années comme
ça vous avez de loiron début des années
50 et vous déclariez à l'époque ça c'est
pas dans votre livre vous déclarez sanaa
devant la presse de l'époque vous dites
je reçois jamais de lettres de femmes
c'est vrai ça les filles vous j'ai reçu
les femmes mais pas les lèvres
bon d'accord vous avez pas besoin de
passer par des lettres c'est ça j'ai
quand même dit quand même un des seuls
qui a pu se permettre de se refuser à
piaf je peux dire ça oui
après ça veut dire qu'elles avaient
elles n avaient d autre part elle en
avait d'autres enfin vous vous avez été
un parmi les nôtres c'est ça qui me
plaisait pas entendre en fait que
physiquement elle n'éprouvait aucune
attirance pour cette fin dites moi alors
y'a un truc que vous racontez pas dans
votre bouquin c'est la nuit que vous
avez passé vous avez pas un jour vous
quitter je crois bruxelles vous vous
passer la frontière franco-belge dans
une voiture avec michel mercier en 58 et
il ya une congère de neige vous tapez
dans la conjure de neige vous passer la
nuit chez des paysans du coin avec
michel mercier
comme vous nous racontez pas ce truc là
dans votre bouquin
parce que vous êtes leur crainte chez
vous en gal ont pas du tout est oublié
j'aimerais bien ça n'a été qu'un
incident fine ouais ouais il s'était
rien passé que michel mercier s'est
alors un jour après en 1960 vous
rencontré celle qui est devenue votre
femme et qui est toujours avec vous
aujourd'hui c'est à dire magali à elles
tiendront tient le coup alors vous
partez en algérie donc après l'échec de
votre votre mariage avec simone vous
êtes à colomb béchar dans une mine où on
sort dessous de charbon par jour c'était
ses pittoresques
il nous était comptable ou installateurs
de frigidaire non non j'ai été agrégées
des contingents table enfin comptables
non j'étais facturés en vérité facturier
wen mais alors là vous commencez à
composer des chansons à écrire des
petits poèmes dans votre temps libre
là-bas colomb béchar et quand vous
rentrez en france vous réparez des
machines à écrire le monter une petite
boîte
alors là je lui voue rentrer un jour
parce que votre vie c'est quand même
c'est le grand hasard de votre vie vous
rentrez aux éditions musicales maurice
vander et au relais moi j'ai lu deux
versions dans votre livre vous dites que
la personne qui tenait les éditions
maurice vander c'est madame le grand
classeur de raymond legrand aidant aidé
en moi j'ai lu dans la presse que
c'était georges et liant le frère de
jacques ayant non pas du tout vander
c'est un lieu de rencontre et puis on en
est parti après trois minutes de
conversation et puis je me suis retrouvé
chez le frère de chez le frère de madame
legrand de la mère de michel wii et qui
tenait l'une
une boutique de musique oui mais
pourquoi dans la presse à un moment on a
dit que c'était georges et liant le
frère de jacques et lyon qui vous avait
la personne que j'ai rencontrée chez van
der c'est georges elia adacore assez
pour s'adapter je sais que lorient qui
m'a dit j'aime ce que vous faites venez
voir maintenant et alors là on vous
emmène voir yves montand qui prend votre
chanson tout de suite oui comment ça
s'est passé
mais très bien à ma grande surprise
d'ailleurs m'enfin bilal je les chante
et moins accompagnés par par georges way
et puis il a dit ça me plaît ça me plaît
je prends j'enregistre est en effet il
avait dit ce qu est la suite assure on
la lui avait vendu ouais et après vous
ai fait une chanson pour dassary qui à
l'époque était quelqu'un d'assez de
c'est connu elle avoue passer une
audition au central de la chanson qui
était quoi un peu comme un comment radio
crochet comme un wave gens là un peu
graine de star quoi
ouais ouais ouais et alors à vos débuts
au à la taverne de la république on
mettez votre nom d' sur le plat du jour
qu'on se serait en fait c'était pas sur
une arbustes et sur la vitrine dehors
ouais rien on faisait le menu menu du
jour et en effet je les ai photographiés
il ya marqué côtes de porc charcutière
robert lamoureux fromage dessert et puis
emballé avec leurs aises et on a eu deux
choses très très importante dans votre
vie la première c'est qu'un jour vous
devez faire une émission de radio avec
quelqu'un qui était bien connu à
l'époque qui ça plombe république vous
l'appelez en nylon écoute je vais pas
venir dans l'émission je suis désolé je
viens pas lui vous en lui faisant gueule
gros comme du poisson pourri et là vous
écrivez en 1h papa maman la bonne et moi
quoi vous avez écrit comment c'est à
dire de dents chez vous avant de partir
on est chez moi
soyons francs dans les toilettes ouais
je suis entré dans les toilettes pour
des raisons vraiment personnel et puis
mais j'avais emmené un vieux cahier sur
lequel j'avais les écrits les trois
premiers vers d'une chanson droit n'est
pas je vais même pas l'attention de la
finir un jour
et puis je me suis dit faut que ça c'est
quelque chose dont cet après midi donc
j'ai donné une suite à la chanson et ça
a été un beau c'est un triomphe
et alors je n'écris pas que l'âge
précise louis vois pas quoi que je me
mets dans l'est alors une autre fois
c'était dans un taxi ce pareil encore un
coup un peu comparable c'est la télé
vous deviez faire une émission dans ris
pas tu qui s'appelait la joie de vivre
alors je vous dire il ya une faute dans
le livre là ya pas de haas pâte dans
votre livre
non on vise pas à y avait 15 ans je
m'excuse non c'est pas ça ne vous savez
occupent ou
c'est un détail certains de ces par son
amant qui étiez la moitié d'avant
j'avais commence pas de ligne pour la
spa doolin il ne semble pas bon alors un
jour dont vous allez faire la joie de
vie vous prenez un taxi pour aller à
l'alhambra est pareil vous avez vous
saviez pas du tout ce que vous aviez
faire il vous est souvenu d'une nouvelle
de mark twain comment s'est passé oui on
m'avait offert un une anthologie des
l'humoriste anglais contemporain dont
j'avais été très frappé par les
aventures de l'oncle podger oui à qui on
demandait de me d'accrocher un tableau
une île et c'est pour appeler un ouvrier
pour ça je vais le faire moi même
l'immeuble était dévastée c'est à dire
qu'elle n'arrivait pas à accrocher le
tableau dans la nouvelle de mark twain à
la mémé l'immeuble et tout le monde y
participe et les mains et ça vous a
donné l'idée de la chasse aux canards
qui est devenu un voilà un des grands
classiques de la deux a de l'humour
francophone on peut dire parce que c'est
connu par tout ça au prince et en assène
deux jours après un attentat à 10,93
hassan ii a été victime d'un attentat
près d'une tentative d'attentât bien
entendu et il a dit le canard est
toujours vivant oui il a vraiment dit
voilà vous devenez une star une star
comique fa vous devenez en quelques mois
une énorme star dont quelques années
quelques années ouest et quand ça au
début des années 50 50 52 53 je peux oui
c'était le plafond oui j'ai ensuite sa
flèche et juste quand tu as honte
alors là bon théâtre gros succès sur
scène disons théâtre cabaret tout ça le
cinéma vous dit jamais été très cinéma
ni traiter les passer parce qu a pas de
public c'est un art qui me restera
étrangers vous dites oui c'est vrai
c'est l'absence de public le fait
d'attendre entre les prises tout ça
c'est pas votre truc quoi elle c'est pas
du tout mon truc
alors vous avez quand même fait au
cinéma alors on pourrait on pour eric
ané en dix ans la preuve que le cinéma
vous restera étrangers c'est que vous
avez fait mais où est donc passée la
7ème compagnie comme vous le savez tout
dire ça peut être crise a été bien
critiquer piana pour qui c'est un film
culte en tous les cas chaque fois qu'il
passe à la télé c'est un triomphe
oui france 3 il a encore passé il ya un
mois je sais plus combien ils ont fait
un énorme m'ont dit lefebvre maccione
après vous faites on a retrouvé la
septième compagnie en 75 et la troisième
la 7ème compagnie au clair de lune ça
s'est moins bien passé là c'était 1 877
pourquoi votre avis parce que c'était la
troisième déjà la deuxième tout ça
pouvait être exclue mais la troisième
parce qu'on aura un drama on aurait
perdu
ouais ouais
alors en 55 vous avez un passager la vie
dans tout ça n'est pas raconter il fait
allusion je dirais dans votre livre
mais des fois vous avez un petit peu de
tendresse pour vous c'est normal quand
on quand on écrit ses mémoires
ce qu'on peut dire en tous les cas si
vous étiez pas préparé au succès vous
avez réussi un peu trop facilement et ça
vous a un peu tourneboulé ladreyt n'ont
sûrement je crois pas qu'on n'échappe à
sa wii qui passent tous par là un moment
où on ne sait pas plus vous aviez honte
de gagner de l'argent aussi facilement
parce que vous êtes d'une origine on ne
l'a pas dit mais enfin votre mère était
receveuse dans les tramways de s'amender
d'une famille très simple et vous avez
un peu honte d'avoir gagné de l'argent
aussi facilement c'est sa honte les
passer du ca va pas jusque là mais en
effet je sentais quelque chose n'était
pas n'en était pas à sa place n'était
pas anormal
ouais et est ce que le public vous en
voulez pas un petit peu aussi d'avoir
quitté votre première femme est ce que
les gens étaient pas un peu aérée
ignoraient qu'ils ignoraient same way il
reprochait pas votre seconde femme
d'avoir une influence sur vous
dangereuses comme ça le grand paul
edwards dans les années 60 vous avez un
vrai trou là au début des années 60 à un
moment j'ai retrouvé un article de
presse où vous dites en titre si vous
aviez la dent dure
vous dites le public m'a oublié tant
mieux avant non mais j'ai viet tan tan
mieu dans le dans la mesure où je n'ai
plus envie de
j'ai plus envie de oui oui vous avez un
vrai avenir d'appartenir au spectacle
c'est ça ce sera moins grave pour lui as
tu poses et rien que la enfin et ce sera
en tout cas beaucoup moins grave pour
moi nous étions quand même une forte
tête parce que déjà on vous aviez la
réputation de certains contrats vous ne
respectiez pas une histoire de notes que
vous aviez accepté jouer knokke et puis
finalement à jour vous êtes mis devant
la glace vous dites je préfère knock
enfin je suis pas louis jouvet mais bon
vous aviez signé il ya eu turlututu
lalala encore et a toujours une
rectification c'est que j'ai perdu le
contrat et protocoles ouais on m'a fait
signer un protocole et moi j'ai cru
qu'un protocole c'était une façon de
cause et on mettait un terme en signant
au bar et au crayon
donc ça ne m'engagerai pas ouais bon
c'était pas ça du tout oui c'est un
contre et une affaire de turlututu aussi
remarqué c'est rigolo mais vous
marcel achard je crois qu'il l'a écrit
pour vous turlututu non
il a écrit en tous les cas et vous vous
avez ajouté des répliques ça s'est très
mal passé avec l'auteur s'est très mal
passé le soir de la générale ça a été un
bide effroyable à la suite de quoi la
direction et en même temps le préfet de
police de paris qui était un ami de la
directrice qui sont montrés dans ma loge
à l'entracte on sait ce que c'est
n'importe quoi mais sauve les meubles et
on n'a pas sauvé les meubles mais comme
on était engagée pour minimum trois mois
au cours des trois mois j'ai tenté quand
même de de réparer les choses avec ce
n'est que je vais plus loin marcel
achard est venu certains soirs il me
disait sur mes ajout à moi ils me
disaient oui ça j'aime pas mais ça
j'adore fatah bref on a tout reconstruit
comme ça à d'accord c'est madame à
charge qui a voulu faire un procès mais
qu'il n'a pas été à son terme ça c'est
des trucs que vous racontez pas dans
votre bouquin que j'ai retrouvé dans la
dans la presse de l'époque vingt treize
années 50 y avait effectivement des
polémiques en plus reteniez tête à la
presse aussi vous étiez une forte tête
oui oui sacré caractère commun alors
vous dites à la fin de votre livre vous
dites il m'a manqué d'être sociable
c'est à dire que vous êtes jamais
vraiment rentré dans le milieu du
spectacle vraiment un je m'en vante pas
la barre à dîner chez vincent auriol
puis la comtesse dont vous parlez dans
le béarn j'ai rencontré j'ai rencontré
et al jean je suis heureux d'avoir
rencontré mais c'est vrai que je suis
pas très dinner et très des jeûneurs n'y
a eu ni très surprise partie des
week-ends chez les amis ben ouais c'est
pas mon genre
est ce que ça vient pas aussi de
finalement dû à un problème de classe
sociale parce que finalement vous êtes
une classe sociale très simple est ce
que vous avez pas s pour un manque
d'habitude comme ça de réduire de
fréquenter les gens baissent de timides
entérinant oui c'est ça oui
manque d'entraînement oui alors en
revanche bon quand je dis vous êtes une
forte tête j'ai eu quand même des jours
ça aussi vous n'en parlez pas dans le
bouquin mais c'est plutôt à votre
honneur y avait une émission qui
s'appelait l'invité du dimanche en 1970
et il avait invité un type qui s'appelle
cyrus presse vanille et lui avait un
document sur jane fonda et jean genet
qui était très anti-américain bon la
direction de la chaîne à l'époque
annuler la présence de cyrus 13 de
vanille vous vous accepté d'y aller et
au moment où vous apprenez qu'on vous
remplacer quelqu'un qui avait été
censuré
vous dites je n'y avais pas pensé plus
tôt courage et ça je n'accepte pas ça
ouais alors la télé c'est que c'est la
première fois que c'est arrivé je sais
que c'est un événement c'est la première
fois qu'on a invité ne venait pas dans
une émission et à la place ils ont passé
un film à la place de votre émission à
la presse de la place de l'invité du
dimanche
ils ont été obligés de passer un passé
un film puisque vous étiez pas là voilà
sinon alors la santé vous lever toujours
à 5 heures du matin oui le plus souvent
il nous fait la sieste quand même oui
faites quoi deux heures de sieste après
c'est ça à peu près ouais je finalement
ce que vous acceptez vous vous êtes de
l'eau depuis 47 et sa 2e en algérie vous
avez pris une cuite vous avez vous
atteint pas pris une j'ai commencé à
picoler vous avez eu peur et musées
voilà et vous vous êtes dit je vais plus
jamais boire de ma vie que je n'ai plus
jamais vu plus jamais jamais non plus
jamais quel courage
on retient que quand vous levez une
coupe de champagne vous l'abus vais pas
vous leur posez pas exactement mellal l
an prochain
ouais alors les rideaux besoin n'est pas
plus que quand vous aviez 40 ans parce
que vous êtes toujours eu des réserves -
pas moins pas plus quoi que finalement
vous avez quand même des migraines zone
est toujours des migraines non plus du
tout depuis que j'ai divorcé depuis j'ai
divorcé
jugé sûr ça peut servir en revanche vous
avez de l'acouphène c'est quoi la des
à-coups fait j'ai des bruits dans les
oreilles en faisant cela vous des fois
comme ça vous entendez des sifflements
ou de recours à des fois tout le temps
les permanents et irréversible il est
versé mais on s'en fait des amis et en
un an ou deux on s'y accoutumer
maintenant je me dis si je les attendais
pas c'est que j'aimerais donc donc là
maintenant vous vivez à voir que vous
aviez coûte pour nous pour qu'on aurait
du coup à tous les cas vous avez l'air
très en forme
bravo ça va bien on était ravi d'avoir
je le dois au public
ouais bah vous avez jeune je crois ce
que je dis merci robert et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de zinal antitube
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus